bonjour et bienvenue en fier que le
magazine santé préparé par la rédaction
de tv fil 78 ce mois ci nous intéressons
tout d'abord au don du sang la période
estivale approche et les demandes sont
toujours très importante
l'association de montigny siens médias
handicap fête cette année ses 9 ans elle
a notamment promouvoir un ancien
patineur artistique philippe candeloro
et puis une structure de psychiatrie
infanto-juvénile inauguré amour pas mais
tout d'abord la lutte contre les fraudes
à la sécurité sociale
il existe un service chargé de lutter
contre ces fraudes au sein de la ceppm
la caisse primaire d'assurance maladie
ce service traite entre eux 500 à 600
dossiers par an et nous avons suivi un
des contrôles
monsieur bonjour c'est l'assurance de la
cpam des yvelines
je me permets de vous contacter pour
vérifier les documents que vous avez
concernant le transport que vous êtes en
train d'effectuer
donc si vous avez la prescription
médicale ce type de contrôle sébastien
gonzalez enquêteurs à la cpam en réalise
presque quotidiennement aux portes des
hôpitaux ou des cliniques au programme
vérification de la prescription médicale
du patient de la présence du macaron
conventionnés sur le pare brise et de la
trousse de soin des éléments
indispensables au remboursement du
transport par la caisse d'assurance
maladie
si le taxi admettant n'a pas la
prescription médicale au moment du
transport
on peut faire un refus lorsqu'il nous
transmet la facture par exemple
s'il n'a pas le macaron aussi n'a pas la
trousse de secours
on peut entamer une procédure
conventionnelle un taxi conventionné
prend en charge les clients et est
ensuite remboursée par la sécurité
sociale
pour ce chauffeur le transport
médicalisé représente 30% de son
activité quotidienne tout à fait normal
parce que beaucoup de beaucoup d'abus et
surtout en ce moment on parle beaucoup
du trou de la sécu donc non non il n'y a
pas de souci là-dessus
après après il ya des règles à respecter
il ya une convention question avec la
sécu important on la respecte mais pas
de soucis quoi depuis 2011 le service de
lutte contre les abus et les fraudes et
centralisées dans cet espace
chaque jour 18 agents à la manière d'un
détective privé repère des fraudes en
tous genres arrêt de travail non
respectés fausses déclarations de
revenus pour obtenir des demandes d'aidé
sociale mais aussi des actes fictifs des
professionnels de santé les ondes qu'on
a vu sur quelqu'un qui avait fraudé sur
ses avis d'arrêt de travail on était
quand même monter à 58 milles euros de
préjudice sur un professionnel de santé
en général on est sur une base de 20 à
40 mille euros d'un nul mais ça peut
monter on a eu l'exemple un infirmier
qui a été condamné pour l'instant
première instance et qui a eu cette
somme est le héros de la nation
chaque année ce service traite entre 550
et 600 dossiers sur le département
après enquête 70% des sommes à payer
sont récupérées soit plus de un million
deux cent mille euros
les progrès de la médecine et
l'allongement de l'espérance de vie font
que les besoins en dons du sang
progressé de 10% depuis cinq ans et
pourtant le nombre de donneurs est lui
resté stable alors un chiffre en par an
en ile de france
cinq cent mille dons du sang sont
nécessaires et seulement 300 milles sont
collectées d'où l'importance évidemment
de donner son sang et nous avons suivi
une collecte mobile à maurepas devant un
centre commercial amour par michael
maass vient donner son sang pour la
première fois dans la salle d'attenté il
remplit un questionnaire avant d'être
reçu par un médecin ou un entretien
couverts par le secret médical
ce dernier va déterminer si michael est
autorisé à donner son sang est la
quantité qu'on va pouvoir lui prélever
en fonction de son poids et de sa taille
pour le jeune homme se sera 480
millilitres le maximum je suis passé
devant et que j'avais jamais donné puis
ma copine m'a dit bah c'est l'heure donc
d'aller faire nos achats qui j'ai donné
j'ai toujours vu le faire mais jamais
l'occasion que j'ai pas peur d une fois
le prélèvement terminé la poche de sang
est récupéré et traité dans les douze
heures
elle va d'abord subir des analyses
biologiques précise un véritable contre
un gars au niveau des maladies on
vérifie au vih les hépatites et la
syphilis jamais la poche de sang de
michael sera transférée sur des sites de
production est divisé en plaquettes
plasma et globules donner son sang un
geste qui prend une dizaine de minutes
rapide et sans douleur surtout
indispensable des groupes sanguins sont
plus recherchées que d'autres au moins
et ab mais en réalité existe 33 system
générique différent dans le sens on sait
jamais de point peut avoir besoin d'un
avis on peut en avoir besoin nous mêmes
protégeons scène dancehall un grave
accident c'est pour sauver les gens le
sang est un médicament unique parce qu'
il ne peut être fabriqué que par nos
frères humains et qu' il sert
principalement aux urgences bientôt
mais aussi à permettre des
chimiothérapies chez tous les malades
qui souffrent de cancer ou de ses fils
alors les besoins de sang en ile de
france sont de l'ordre de 1500
traitement par jour
actuellement on est largement de sa 1/2
chette entrées quotidiennes de dons
quant à mickaël on le retrouve en fin de
collecte à la pause collation pour une
première bilan de ce très bien passé
donc je pense que je recommencerai les
hommes peuvent donner au maximum si
froid leur sens dans l'année 4 fois pour
les femmes
depuis neuf ans et bassins proyart ini
mon teint et son association se bat pour
la reconnaissance dans les médias des
personnes en situation de handicap
sébastien proyart vient de fêter cet
anniversaire à paris en compagnie d'un
des parrains de l'association philippe
candeloro passe à 6 de se mettre dans la
peau d'un aveugle quand on voit sans
problème
l'association média handicap basée à
montigny le bretonneux sensibilise les
valides aux problématiques des
handicapés depuis neuf ans maintenant
objectif final permettre aux handicapés
d'accéder aux métiers des médias et de
la communication
l'association reçoit régulièrement le
soutien de personnalités
cette année c'est philippe candeloro qui
a fait le déplacement et beaucoup de
boulot en france pour changer un petit
peu la vie des handicapés bon d'essayer
de faire des choses sur les trottoirs
les choses comme ça je le vois même
quand je veux faire du roller par
exemple c'est pas évident de trouver des
belles routes ou en me disant mais
comment ils font les fauteuils roulants
et peuvent pas circuler et des failles
assaillent a pas de trottoir et ou alors
c'est des pavés wells s'est pas adapté
bilan de ces neuf dernières années de
belles rencontres mais aussi des
avancées dans la prise en compte du
handicap
on a interviewé george clooney matt
damon en veste et ados call on est
soutenu par le président gilles jacob du
facile de local il n'y a pas que
l'aspect people est aussi l'axé
sensibilisation ça tient au mâcon on m'a
contacté pour que je mette en situation
de handicap et partez ingénieurs qui
vont travailler dans le domaine de
l'accessibilité de la voirie dont pierre
aussi des actions de fond toujours en
place jouer sur scène avec edouard baer
ou encore tag et hier contre courant en
kayak avec un champion olympique malgré
son handicap sébastien première se fixe
en permanence des défis sa manière à lui
d'assumer sa différence et d'en faire
une force
un nouveau centre de psychiatrie
infanto-juvénile inauguré amour pas le
site dépend du centre charcot de plaisir
il accueille des enfants et des
adolescents atteints de troubles mentaux
reportage après celle de rambouillet il
ya un an le centre hospitalier
jean-martin-charcot de plaisir a
inauguré une nouvelle structure de
psychiatrie infanto juvénile en plein
centre-ville de maurepas et leur groupe
l'ancienne structure de maurepas plus la
structure de la verrière qui a été
rapatriée ici pour fusionner les équipes
et donna un plus un plateau technique
mieux équipées et plus plus agréable aux
enfants au total 1000 enfants et
adolescents atteints de troubles mentaux
qui sont accueillis tout au long de
l'année pour des consultations ou des
ateliers thérapeutiques pour prendre en
charge leur pathologie
cinq médecins pédopsychiatres et une
trentaine de personnels médical dont un
nouveau psychologue à mi temps
ces nouveaux locaux aménagés sur 600 m²
sont considérées comme un atout en plus
on a un mobilier qui est adapté donc
tous et sur roulettes on pousse son
plein dans les couloirs on exploite la
seule solution veut l'atelier lumineux
permet aussi d'utiliser plus de matériel
et de développer des projets avec les
adolescents des projets parfois
étonnants c'est peut-être le seul
endroit ici me savent que c'est pour eux
et que ils vont pouvoir amener leur
projet comme il
et que les gens travaillent voilà avec
eux
alors service on leur fait faire des
armes en carton des cartons de
récupération pour tirer des élastiques
par exemple et leur apprend ainsi comme
enfin maîtriser la violence ce pôle de
pédopsychiatrie concerne 90 communes qui
s'étendent de saint quentin en yvelines
jusqu'à rambouillet ce nouveau numéro
deux chez cap est presque terminée avant
de nous quitter vous en avez l'habitude
on va jeter un coup d'oeil sur l'agenda
du mois les événements santé à ne pas
manquer on va commencer d'abord par ce
colloque qui a lieu le 16 mai à l'ufr
des sciences de la santé sur le thème
vieillissement et mobilité l'adaptation
de l'offre de mobilité aux besoins des
personnes à mobilité réduite et donc
sera lui entre 13h et 20h
le 30 mai une journée de dépistage du
cancer de la peau qui aura lieu à
l'institut de promotion de la santé
cet attrape les 1er et 2 juin une
opération de dépistage du diabète à
l'occasion du défi nature ça se passera
à la base de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines
et puis enfin les du 5 au 8 juin le
traditionnel forum santé orchestrée par
le ps il aura lieu au centre commercial
régional espace saint quentin voilà ce
nouveau numéro de check up est
maintenant terminé merci de votre
attention je vous donne rendez vous le 7
juin pour une nouvelle émission d'ici là
portez vous bien
oh